brad pitt rocks a skirt to the berlin
premiere of bullet train
why well fashion of course it's such a
subjective thing
but as he explains on the red carpet
there's also an added perk
let's break down his full ensemble
[Music]
brad hits the scene with his linen knee
length skirt which he pairs with a
matching brown cardigan a salmon colored
button-up and topping it off with combat
boots also on display a rare sighting of
the actor's leg tattoos oh i see what
you're doing and this is just the latest
stop on the bullet train press tour
yep that's brad pitt and his castmates
getting their boogie on at the paris
premiere
the film's producer kelly mccormick
starts off with some funky moves walking
with director david leach in the cast
they brought that same energy
[Music]
brian tyree henry bust a move with aaron
taylor johnson and brad he was a playful
goofball all night
[Applause]
[Music]
and the love fest continues on stage the
actors don't waste any time opening up
about their special bond oh man i don't
want to spoil it for you man but i love
this guy we have a lot of love and a lot
of care i can't vote for this guy so we
played it we had a good time so you get
to see this chemistry between these two
assassins and for brad the guy is just
truly stoked to be out living his best
life it was just in the middle of
lockdown you know that that point where
we were all getting a little crazy a
little cuckoo a little dark a little
depressed and it came the script
with great characters
funniest and it just seemed like the
perfect sad for this time and it's so
great to be here now to be here in paris
to like let out the summer we're all
here together and it's just it's really
great and yeah brad's fit at the
parisian photo call also deserves a
closer look
he dons a bright orange jacket pairing
it with a v-neck tee and some aviators
you're going to want to hear the whole
story brad's co-star joey king even
secures a selfie for instagram she
writes in the caption quote bullet train
crew takes paris what's happening to
your face maybe there was a little head
trauma maybe
i i gotta get off this train whether
it's looking good in fight scenes or on
the red carpet joey recently told e.t
that brad can do it all
what did you learn from brad about stunt
work
i mean brad is just like so agile and
impressive and gorgeous so i mean
there's a lot to learn from someone who
can pull off all of those at the same
time
[Music]
you